franche comté il ya six centre
d'information et de recrutement des
forces armées donc belfort besançon
auxerre mâcon nevers et dijon bien sûr
donc dans certains santé aussi l'armée
de l'air et la marine
mais là principalement l'armée de terre
dans les six centres et voilà nous
recrutons à balai c'est vrai qu'on
cuisine nouvel or non voilà 800 emplois
d'ici la fin de l'année le rythme annuel
entre 800 et 1000 voilà normalement le
riz en bourgogne franche comté bourgogne
franche comté le rythme devrait pas trop
changer après le bond le chiffre peut
fluctuer en fonction des besoins
nationaux
voilà donc ont cessé d'aider des jeunes
qui candidatent en fonction de leur
dossier leurs compétences là c'est
qu'ils considérable avec nous il ya
forcément des parents des grands parents
probablement aussi je l'espère des
jeunes qui se disent tiens pourquoi pas
moi alors quels sont les critères de
recrutement dans l'armée à ce que c'est
c'est moi qui fait la démarche
commence alors la démarche déjà il ya le
site internet s'engager point fr pour
candidater et déjà prendre après contact
et on convoquera le jeune ce rappel
téléphonique afin d'avoir un entretien
avec un conseiller en recrutement qui va
le suivre du début à la fin
donc les conditions sont simples c'est
200 diplôme à bac +5 pour un engagement
dans de 17 ans et demi jusqu'à 32 ans
mais on propose aussi des formations de
préparation militaire découverte donc
qui dure des stages d'une semaine
pendant les vacances scolaires pour
découvrir un peu notre monde
à partir de quel âge à partir de 16 ans
parfois c'est à 16 ans et demi je peux
mettre mon fils ou ma fille voilà fils
vous fille enfin les prix des cartons
des féminines voilà il ya la mixité dans
les armées donc c'est prévu pour ça donc
ça permet de découvrir déjà le monde
militaire pendant cinq jours porter le
treillis manger des rations faire
quelques activités militaires tu vois
votre voisin qui sourit parce qu est ce
que vous l'avez fait cette préparation
militaire en tanins on est tout à fait à
l'âge de 16 ans dans un régiment
d'artillerie près de lyon ouais ouais
et pour vous votre engagement ça s'est
passé comment c'était c'était
obligatoire où vous vouliez vraiment
haletant dans l'armée j'ai toujours eu
le désir de devenir un militaire je
pense que c'est un par rapport à
l'éducation que j'ai reçue et la fierté
par rapport à mon papa qui a effectué
son service militaire et donc tout jeune
dès l'âge de 10-12 ans je commençais à
enfiler de tri et away à chaque étape
à chaque étape j'ai voulu j'ai voulu
m'engager donc par une préparation
militaire à 16 ans un engagement de
réservistes opérationnels dans un
régiment près de chez nous à auxonne
et puis à l'âge de 18 ans dans l'armée
d'activé pouvoir faire mon métier
d'accord je regarde notre ami de yoga du
rire qui sera avec nous pour une
démonstration d'ici quelques minutes
vous avez fait votre service militaire
parce que vous êtes de la génération de
ce mois le premier qui avons fait
peut-être le service militaire
oui tout à fait je sais dans les marines
à l'esprit tout en corse
c est un excellent souvenir ou pas oui
c'est une belle expérience
c'est une expérience voilà ses
excellents souvenirs je ne dirais pas ça
mozart garde un très bon souvenir
perçoit peut-être que tout le monde s'en
fout mais moi je vous dis que ça s'est
très bien passé
voilà pour vous entonnant ce morceau ça
s'est tellement bien passé vous en avez
fait un livre
l'engagement bon alors pourquoi pourquoi
parce que déjà lâche 2 à l'âge de 19 10
ans en classe de cm2 j'ai eu des
difficultés donc j'ai dû aller consulter
une orthophoniste et c'est d'une part
pour me prouver à moi que tu sortie de
ces difficultés là est le sujet qui est
qui et l'armée ben c'est parce que c'est
ma fierté de servir et je voulais que
cet écrit servent et donc les bénéfices
du livre seront reversés à la cellule
d'aidé aux blessés de l'armée de terre
pour sow pour soutenir nos familles et
nos blessés qui sont qui reviennent
d'opérations extérieures traumatisés ou
blessés tout cas c'est une belle
revanche sur l'auto fournissent tout
lâcher parce que adjudant chef vous en
recevez vous de temps en temps des des
jeunes comme en tenait encore une fois
fille ou garçon qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés à leur élocution d'écriture
que sais-je encore c'est compliqué
parfois de dire à ces jeunes c'est pas
possible ou alors ça sera possible plus
tard alors rien n'est impossible pour un
jeune qui veut candidate et qui veut
rentrer dans les armes et nous on
l'accompagnent ça fait parti d'un proche
de projet professionnel donc d'un jeune
candidat nous
voit on sent projet professionnel en
fonction de son envie on me fait passer
des évaluations mais tout le monde peut
y arriver
après on a juste par rapport aux
évaluations le projet professionnel en
accord avec le candidat donc il ya
toujours un emploi à pourvoir ou
quelqu'une compétences que la personne
peut ignorer d'elle-même et nous on peut
détecter certaines compétences enlisé
environ 800 emplois en bourgogne france
comté
ça représente beaucoup de métier quels
sont les métiers qui aujourd'hui
recrutent dans la région dans l'armée
alors on a 300 spécialités différentes
parce que le seul métier c'est le métier
de soldat d'abord on s'engage pour être
soldat donc au service de la patrie au
service de la république
donc on s'engage d'abord pour ça et
ensuite après on fait un métier
différent
enfin différents le métier de soldat est
différent mais les autres spécialités
non on embauche des cuisiniers des
boulangers des secrétaires
administratives
on embauche de tous à peu près 300 à 400
spécialités différentes donc tout le
monde à sa place comme dans le civil
dans les armées quand on s'engage dans
l'armée il ya des questions à se poser
quand même à un moment
est-ce qu'on va continuer ou presque le
métier intéressant donc 100% propose au
début on est sous contrat donc des
contrats de un an trois ans cinq ans est
le jeune à qui ça plairait plus au bout
d'un certain temps il peut
éventuellement partir c'est sous contrat
et après les gens les plus intéressants
ils peuvent rester n'y a pas de souci en
tonnage imagine que vous l'avenir le
voyez dans l'armée oui tout à fait je
souhaite faire carrière
ouais il est question qui vous est posée
quand même au début parce qu'après tout
ce répit ne pas vous plaire
effectivement ça aurait pu après j'étais
ans j'étais réellement motivés et
réellement renseigner donc donc j'ai
passé beaucoup de qualification qui
m'ont kim ont continué à poursuivre
cette voie et est donc je vais continuer
à pratiquer des stages pour pour évoluer
alors vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
vous avez fait une préparation militaire
on peut la faire je le rappelle à partir
de 16 ans filles ou garçons pendant une
semaine vous n'avez jamais eu envie par
exemple aussi de vous engager dans un
collège militaire parce qu'il existe des
collèges militaire alors il existe je
pense qu'à cette époque je n'avais pas
les feux les
les bonnes informations et donc j'en ai
pas eu l'opportunité je vais vous dire
un exemple parce qu'il en existe
seulement deux en france peut-être que
vous connaissez celui d'autun qui se
trouve en saône et loire nous avons nous
suivi la rentrée des élèves de 6e
une entrée au carré vous allez voir les
routes pour regarde en avant marche
allez on y va
c'est une rentrée millimétré au pas bien
décidé une démarche au carré le colle
bien plier tous les détails comptent
ces cinquante petits nouveaux ont
seulement 11 ans et cet uniforme sera
désormais leur seconde peau c'est pas
très classique mais on est fiers parce
que c'est
on a beaucoup travaillé pour pouvoir
entrer dans cette école et puis
aujourd'hui c'est y est on est là et si
on a réalisé notre rêve donc on est très
fier de le porter si jamais cet après
midi vous êtes perdus vous venez nous
voir au bureau ne pleurait la chef de
peloton c'est un peu la maman de la
troupe
elle rassure mais doit surtout
transmettre la rigueur vous savez déjà
vous mettre au garde à vous on est
d'accord est en position de repos bien
le rythme est compliqué 6h30 du matin de
vous jusqu'à l'étude du soir jusqu'à 19
heures donc c'est des grosses journées
donc au fur à mesure ça va ça va venir
ça va rentrer dans trois semaines
y'a pas de soucis ils vont déjà
connaître tous les rouages de
l'établissement
aux portes du morvan le collège
militaire situé en contrebas de
l'emblématique lycée est un
établissement quasi unique et très
demandé les règles de vie au sein du
collège
vous en connaissez déjà certaines ici
quasiment seuls les enfants de
militaires et de fonctionnaires peuvent
avoir leur chance
les élèves viennent ainsi de toute la
france c'est le cas des tas originaire
de lyon pour la réputation travailler
tous ne rêve pas d'être militaire loin
de là c'est simplement suivre une
scolarité un peu autrement c'est la
cohésion le respect beaucoup
d'insistance sur le respect dans le
respect bien sûr de l'adulte des
consignes mais le respect aussi entre
eux donc il ya souvent à un important
travail qui est fait
loin de leur famille elles les élèves
sont ensemble 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24
de quoi renforcer l'esprit de groupe est
fils unique et moi j'ai toujours voulu
savoir ce que c'est qu'avoir un frère
une soeur battre ici ça me fait penser
cela les parois ils vont beaucoup nous
manquer dont - c'est d'un côté d'un côté
ciel c'est positif parce que c'est nous
rapproche et la maturité
depuis deux ans cette école de
l'excellence affiche un taux de réussite
de 100 % au brevet des collèges
la discipline 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 l'engagement finalement c'est
comme alarmante non oui tout à fait je
pense que c'est
c'est une très bonne démarche pour les
jeunes et en ça peut les aiguiller vers
une carrière militaire mais justement
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces jeunes
qui peuvent être avec nous ses parents
qui nous écoutent ses grands parents qui
sont devant leur écran de télé qui se
disent tiens pourquoi pas mon fils ma
petite fille et ben moi je les encourage
à s'engager en revanche les encourage
aussi à bien se renseigner et et à
apprendre tout en compte parce que parce
que des fois on peut on peut vouloir
s'engager et et choisir un régiment
parfois très loin de chez soi
et après on peut se rendre compte que
c'est
la vie familiale est un peu compliqué
donc si on est décidé à s'engager on se
renseigne bien on fait tout le parcours
de recrutement qui est indiqué dans le
livre et qui je l'espère pourront les
aider et à
et puis après on se lance dans une belle
carrière bien bien se renseigner ça veut
dire adieu d'un chef et hors écart net
c'est pousser la porte d'un cirfa vous
l'avais dit en bourse comptait il ya
plusieurs bureaux
c'est avant cela aller faire un petit
tour sur internet s'engager point fr
pour retrouver effectivement toutes les
carrières qu'on peut embrasser là on
parle de l'armée de terre c'est un
exemple mais il ya l'armée de l'air il
ya la marine
voilà il ya toutes nos armées française
et ça représente des centaines d'emplois
ne le dira jamais assez un bourgogne
franche comté
c'est absolument considérable le conseil
que vous vous donnez aux jeunes qui sont
avec nous
bach qui n'hésitent pas à franchir le
port aux mains pour se renseigner se
faire évaluer donc ouvrir un dossier
candidate et se faire évaluer et mettre
voir le mettre en relation leurs projets
professionnels et la formation qu'on
peut leur proposer pour trouver un
métier et après qui t'a quitté les armes
et plus tard et leur faire dans le civil
derrière et puis il ya toujours le
fameux bons plans moi j'ai passé mon
permis de conduire comme ça dans l'armée
parce que on le sait tous est compliqué
aujourd'hui de passer par exemple permis
de conduire est ce que par exemple si je
viens vous voir que je suis sélectionné
que je vais faire mon premier contrat je
peux à un moment dire dans la balance se
maintient mais j'aimerais bien passer
mon permis de conduire ça fait partie
des petites choses en plus qu'on peut
avoir
ça fait partie des petites choses en
plus tout à fait le permis est toujours
d'actualité dans les armées bon il ya
certains postes où on engage déjà avec
le permis et d'autre on peut leur offrir
l'opportunité de passer le permis de
conduire à la fois véhicules légers les
plus beaux gabarits on n'a pas parlé
argent mais il faut quand même les yeux
dans les yeux qu'on en parle parce que
évidemment que c'est une question que
l'on doit vous posez on est recruté à
partir de combien alors les plus jeunes
les contrats d'un an ses 800 euros c'est
renouvelable quatre faux bon ça c'est
des cursus particulier plus jeunes c'est
à dire à partir de 18 ans
17 ans et demi 18 ans en fonction d'un
certain cursus surtout pour les contrats
d'un an donc les volontaires de l'armée
de terre ont touché à peu près une somme
de 800 euros par mois donc cedex nra c
cnet c'est une jeune willow j'ai
instruit et toujours les 75% et bien
voilà quarante cinq jours de congés oui
c'est important
voilà après le contrat classique donc
militaires du rang donc engagé
volontaire de l'armée terre ils vont
toucher 1280 euros nets et après les
sous-officiers 1350
voilà une belle carrière et ça va ça
continue évolué au fil des mots fil des
années mais nous aussi on va